after I got kicked out of college I'm
just outside now yeah and I'm like I'm
not going back to L.A it's too much
money out here yeah and PeeWee ended up
getting out of prison and then I'm like
yeah I mean that's like my
brother-in-law so wait peewee's your
brother-in-law yeah my so his bro
his brother was [__] with my sister
that lives in Atlanta yeah so you
already had like yeah yeah are they
still together nah okay they broke up
they was together for like years years
like yeah I mean that [__] just because
you like people like Family Guy yeah so
it's like [__] all right boom what we
gonna do he came home from jail he just
like me right like [__] it yeah I mean
we should start [__] around rapping
doing what we was doing crazy that's how
it started because it was PeeWee like
like I think I kind of started to hear
about Peewee and like
this was like oh wait I was gonna say
like 2019
yeah yeah
he was dope man I feel like he doesn't
get enough love or props when it comes
to like PVA in the social is he supposed
to be man him and scooter I feel like
are just [__] they just they're like
for whatever reason just straight Ledges
they can't AK snap out of the street
legend you got peewee's dope man yeah so
you end up working with Peewee
how does this because I met you through
Kid Ink so how do you become because
were you like bat gang essentially yeah
so how do you end up working with ink
because you were like his shadow so you
guys are related so you and ink are
related I didn't know that I just saw
related oh okay I see is my real cousin
his wife yeah yeah shout out to his wife
by the way I'm so happy that we have a
hip-hop couple that's [__] locked in
still together they've been together
since high school that [__] is like yeah
that ain't going nowhere oh my God they
are locked in okay yeah I always so I
didn't know that you were related to his
wife who's a sweetheart shout out to her
she's amazing
um I always just assumed that like you
were just like our artist that he [__]
with that was in town and like it also
probably didn't hurt that you were like
yeah baby back there right so when you
guys are on the road I'm like well he's
kind of got a street guy on the crew he
was understanding to play yeah hell no
that's that's family so it was just like
yeah I was [__] up he like man come
on let me help you out let's go because
I he taught me how to like like rap and
put that [__] together he used to really
record me while I was trying no he's so
good at like people don't understand
he's a great producer he's a great
engineer and he's just like yeah he
understands like the musicality of like
song structure and like melody in such a
crazy way and that's why he can't make
he can't go to making them down songs
right like he is not in them yeah it's
like making music that's not making
music but like I even think like the
first record that like really went to
radio was time of your life which is
like such a crazy record when you hear
you're just like this song could pop at
any anywhere Timeless yeah even even
hell and back it it creeped on everybody
like Helen Back wasn't even like the
[__] song that was picked to hit the
radio is that the one that MGK was on
that you could tell them now
MGK record that went uh Platinum back
out of nowhere I remember we'll post it
but it's crazy to see like so so I don't
know
so that whole that whole era like you
end up working with ink what what at
what point in time was this was this
prior to him really kind of commercially
having his moment because I remember he
was doing like
him and
I remember
when ink came to Phoenix early on it was
him and either Dizzy Wright or Hopsin
dizzy right it was dizzy and Phoenix it
was dizzy yep and I remember the show
sold out but everybody was there to see
Kid Ink and my boy was there and he was
sending me pictures like bro the [__]
this kid ain't dude is like and I'd
heard of him but I had always when I
when I heard his name and I saw he was a
guy with a lot of tattoos I was like oh
yeah of course there's a guy named Kid
Ink with a lot of tattoos because there
was another guy that was like that ink
monster yes and I was like yeah of
course they use the always they used to
always confuse but then you'd hear
kidding some music and you'd be like oh
this goes crazy yeah so you think that
comes from understanding me what year
did you guys like what year did you
officially start rolling with him and
learning music from him and doing all
that
two thousand
after I got shot in the neck for sure
well right before I got shot in the neck
like 2009 oh so early yeah
I bet that was what you said when I
started doing the music but I've been
supporting them since like 2000 like
eight like right when he as soon as he
start doing the rap thing uh because
like he was doing the producers you know
producers are quiet you don't know what
he was making beats for people yeah but
you don't know like Sean Kingston and
yeah and Diddy and all type of different
people nip okay so we're talking about
Kid Ink um
obviously uh would you say Inc was kind
of like
your real real introduction into like
that was my big break into the industry
I mean you get to see the world right
well well maybe not the world yeah no
the world well not Canada though well I
can't go to Canada I was just saying
that's the only place you can't see is
Canada right Australia can't go to
Australia
but you were able to go to Europe you
were able to go to some of those like
crazy European tours
yeah we're opening for one of those
tours yeah yeah over there yeah but I
went multiple times like I've been
overseas so many times with him it was
Unreal I was starting to feel like I
wasn't from America anymore for a second
that shit's crazy because we were out
there 90 days at a time I feel like once
a year he'd go on one of those runs
right here like for sure he go running
the bag up right before Christmas did
you ever do Dubai with him
um I never did Dubai with him okay never
did Dubai with him because once Dubai
started coming around I start having
like legal issues to where I couldn't
travel at all